völlig erschöpft mit schrecklichem Durst
gerettet diese Brite 30 Jahre alt hat
unglaubliches Glück gehabt ja nachdem er
mit seinem Kajak mitten im Ärmelkanal
untergegangen war hat er sich gerettet
und zwar auf dieser kleinen Boje ganze
zwei Tage lang
[Musik]
ein junger Mann gestrandet nicht auf
einer Insel nur auf einer schiffsboje
ein Quadratmeter mitten im Ärmelkanal
hierhin hat er sich gerettet dieser 30
Jahre alte Brite Kajak-Fahrer sein
aufblasbares Boot auf hoher See
gekämpfert Seenot im 17 Grad kühlen
Wasser als Rettung bleibt zunächst nur
die Boje doch weit und breit niemand Tag
und Nacht zwei Tage und zwei Nächte der
Junge Kajak-Fahrer beginnt Muscheln von
der Boje zu kratzen gegen den Hunger
gegen die Erschöpfung und dann kommt
endlich Hilfe dieser holländische
Fischkutter die Madeleine sie rettet ihn
ein Wunder so sagtest die Besatzung des
Kutters Helden die Momente der Rettung
er hat überlebt erschöpft aber
unverletzt Daumen hoch
ein junger Kajak-Fahrer der alleine über
den Ärmelkanal wollte er wurde zum
Robinson cruso auf dieser Boje
[Musik]